demonstrationen verboten ich begrüße
diese entscheidung
sie war gleichwohl eine schwierige
entscheidung weil zwischen verschiedenen
grundrechten abgewogen werden musste
klar ist wir haben artikel 5 des
grundgesetzes meinungsfreiheit artikel 8
des grundgesetzes versammlungsfreiheit
die ist dem berliner senat auch
besonders wichtig deswegen lassen wir
versammlungen in großem umfang seit
geraumer zeit auch wir dazu immer
versehen mit auflagen für den
infektionsschutz mund nasenschutz ein
meter fünfzig abstand haben aber
begrenzungen der menge der
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer
aufgehoben also insofern in berlin
herrscht versammlungsfreiheit
aber es gibt eben auch den artikel 2 des
grundgesetzes das recht auf
unversehrtheit des lebens und diese
unterschiedlichen grundrechte müssen
miteinander abgewogen werden
wir hatten am ersten august hier in
berlin eine anti corona demonstration
bei der wir im vorfeld entsprechende
auflagen tragen des nasen schutzes
einhaltung des sicherheitsabstandes
beauflagt hatten die organisatoren
dieser demonstration am ersten august
sind auch auf diese auflagen eingegangen
haben ein hygiene konzept vorgelegt und
wir mussten dann aber bei der
demonstration und bei der nachfolgenden
kundgebung feststellen dass diese
auflagen ganz bewusst missachtet worden
sind und aus dieser erfahrung wissen wir
dass wir am wochenende mehrere
demonstrationen in der stadt zu erwarten
in der stadt zu erwarten hätten
bei denen wieder ganz bewusst gegen den
infektionsschutz verstoßen hat deshalb
ist diese entscheidung der berliner
versammlungsbehörde keine entscheidung
gegen das versammlungsrecht sondern eine
entscheidung für den infektionsschutz
versammlungsfreiheit bedeutet ja nicht
bewusst gegen geltendes recht verstoßen
zu taufen und angesichts steigender
infektionszahlen
in berlin steigender infektionszahlen in
deutschland ist ein solches treffen
mehreren tausend menschen von denen wir
sicher ausgehen können dass sie bewusst
gegen infektionsschutz auflagen
verstoßen wollen und verstoßen werden
ein zu hohes risiko deshalb hat die
versammlungsbehörde dieser entscheidung
getroffen und es steht zu dieser
entscheidung
vielen dank
die berliner polizei wird am wochenende
mit mehreren tausend beamtinnen und
beamten in der stadt seien auch
unterstützt von bereitschaftspolizisten
und polizisten aus anderen bundesländern
und auch vom rund um dieses verbot
entsprechend durchzusetzen
nein das wäre nicht legitim
versammlungsrecht sagt er ganz
ausdrücklich dass das recht auf
versammlung geschützt wird unabhängig
vom gegenstand der jeweiligen
versammlung also rechts verbieten links
zu lassen geht geht nicht das ist vom
grundgesetz nicht gedeckt das ist aber
auch nicht grundlage des verbots und
dieser stelle grundlage des verbots ist
das bewusst gegen infektionsschutz
regeln verstoßen werden soll und bewusst
dann diese möglichkeiten des
versammlungsrechtes ausgenutzt werden
sollen um rechtsverstöße zu beginn und
das lässt sich der staat nicht gefallen
wir dürfen uns nicht auf der nase
herumtanzen lassen
ja ich denke dass wir damit zu rechnen
haben jedenfalls ist angekündigt dass
das juristisch angegriffen wird das ist
auch normal gesunden freies land und die
entscheidung der versammlungsbehörde
bedeutet ja eine einschränkung des
grundrechts auf versammlungsfreiheit
zugunsten eines anderen grundrechtes und
das muss von gerichten sicherlich
abgewogen werden und wir werden das auch
bis in die letzte instanz durchfechten
[Musik]
das ist der weg den wir am ersten august
diesen jahres gewählt haben auflagen zu
erteilen die sind alle auch bestätigt
worden von den anmeldern der versammlung
dass hygiene konzept was vorgelegt
worden ist zum ersten august war in sich
auch stimme ich auch die räume auf der
straße des 17 juni hätten am ersten
august ausgereicht um den entsprechenden
abstand einzuhalten
man muss dann aber feststellen dass das
bewusst bewusste verstöße dagegen gibt
und deswegen ist dann am ersten august
auch dieser kundgebung aufgelöst worden
aber wir haben alle gesehen dass die
auflösung hat derart großen
menschenmenge wenn sie denn widerwillig
ist mehrere stunden in anspruch nimmt
und dass das dann dazu führt dass
menschen gefährdet werden
auch polizisten und polizisten in ihrer
gesundheit gefährdet werden
und das ist nicht hinzunehmen
berlin kann nicht zum ort von solchen
kroner leugner demonstrationen werden
wird ja inzwischen deutschlandweit und
europaweit auch dazu aufgerufen
und ich kann nicht bewusst dieses risiko
für die kolleginnen kollegen der polizei
aber eben auch für die teilnehmer und
teilnehmer in kauf nehmen und aus dieser
erfahrung vom ersten august treffen wir
jetzt diese entscheidung für das
wochenende
möglichkeiten gerade geschildert habe
versuchen wir es wieder mit der
durchsetzung von nasen schutz da muss
man aber klar sagen dass das ein aufruf
ist und jeder aus der erfahrung vom
ersten august tausende menschen waren
diesem aufruf folgen und
meinungsfreiheit ist ja nicht
eingeschränkt meinungsfreiheit ist klar
und die meinung der potenziellen
demonstrantinnen und demonstranten ist
uns ja bekannt ist auch der
öffentlichkeit bekannt dass dieser
versuch gestartet wird diese regeln ganz
bewusst zu missachten und deshalb war
für uns klar dass wir an dieser stelle
regeln aufgestellt haben regeln zum
schutz der gesundheit von menschen
aufgestellt haben aus gutem grund
schauen sie sich bitte in anderen
europäischen ländern um schauen sie sich
bitte in anderen ländern dieser welt um
welche gesundheitlichen gefährdungen mit
corona verbunden waren und auch noch
zukünftig verbunden sind dass diese
regeln gelten und das unsere aufgabe ist
diese regeln durchzusetzen
deshalb war eine schwere entscheidung
aber wir haben sie getroffen wir sind
ein demokratisches freies land
es gibt selbstverständlich die
möglichkeit seine meinung zu äußern auch
öffentlich zu äußern sofern man nicht
gegen recht verstößt
aber wenn man bewusst gegen geltendes
recht verstossen möchte dann muss der
staat auch deutlich machen dass er
gewillt ist seine regeln durchzusetzen
deshalb habe ich die erwartung an die
demonstrantinnen und demonstranten
dass sie dieses verbot akzeptieren wir
werden sehen wie gerichte dazu
entscheiden aber vor allem habe ich die
erwartung dass das am wochenende in
berlin nicht zu gewalttätigkeiten kommt
denn das was ich inzwischen in den
letzten stunden androhungen erfahre was
die mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter auch der
berliner polizei an persönlichen
bedrohungen erfahren ist so nicht
hinzunehmen
das zeigt ein erhebliches
gewaltpotenzial wie er die
teilnehmerschaft auch sehr heterogen ist
sind der ganz klaren rassistische
organisation
die dort auf rufen bundesweit und
deshalb meine damen es geht am
wochenende eigentlich nicht darum gegen
korona zu demonstrieren sondern das ist
eine demonstration gegen unsere
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
geplant es geht nicht darum die
regierung für entscheidungen zu
kritisieren die regierung kann für
entscheidungen kritisiert werden wir
sind auch nur menschen ganz
selbstverständlich aber es geht ganz
klar darum und zur demokratie in frage
zu stellen die auch des lebens ist
miteinander lebens in deutschland in
frage zu stellen und so freiheit in
frage zu stellen und das muss jeder
wissen der sich am sonntag trotz des
verbots auf die straße begibt